je demande uniquement aux immigrés
qu'ils fassent comme je ne crie mon
amour de la france j'ai même écrit un
livre là-dessus avec brio très avec eux
et méritée d'un meeting on allait faire
avec une certaine idée de la france et
nous disions dans ce livre ouais la
france effectivement pour certains c'est
une idée mais où cette idée faut quand
même la respecter car ya des règles des
normes
il ya des valeurs ne vient pas en france
pour apporter la charade ac - alexandre
lisa ne pose aucun problème quand c'est
une religion privatiser j'en parlais
avec le recteur de la mosquée de ta vie
tes laisse la bâtisse pose un problème
quand tu es les islamistes c'est
l'islamisme qui provient du simple
facile à gérer
on va revenir sur le débat calmement
j'arrive je veux d'abord dire une chose
c'est que à la pause j'ai eu plein de
messages de gens qui écoutent l'émission
qui sont passionnés par balances ton
post qui trouvait les missions inaudible
et qui prennent pas de plaisir ce soir à
l'écouté moi je vous écoutait beaucoup
d'attention j'essayais oui en disant
vous allez c'est parti allait me donner
une leçon elle m'intéresse lecture est
assez pact arim vous n'avez pas être
alors tout cas je n'ai pas dit le mot
comme un pays d'accueil sais pas si on
va pas revenir là dessus au c'est bon
allez encore karim zéribi impossible de
dire au monde ce sera les items possible
s'il s'est totalement détestable on
parle d'immigration
et voilà que ça fait une demi heure que
nous parle d'islam et de musulmans
dressés vous car parler moi je n'ai pas
parlé s'il vous plaît car vie des
carriers mots comme un diable vous
n'allez pas vous avez préféré
allez-y on n'a rien ay maladive et vous
les avez gardé mais des fois mais les
autres sur la tuerie que tu nous as
koupèla la laisser aux poignets
j'ai nommé ici j'aimerais que ma wii
peut couper les autres mais faut surtout
et notre hymne national
la clp au social à l'elysée c'est un
truc de des standing digne laissera
chmagh analyse met un truc de dingue
dames et chevaliers que j'ai trouvé plus
sympa autant dire qu on va faire un test
arribart en parler on va voir allez dis
donc je disais migration l'immigration
que l'on a que dans le pays à 40 %
d'européens
on nous parle que d'islam de musulmans
de mosquées de terrorisme
les amis c'est pas le sujet vous êtes
trompé de débat on fait partie qui me
gratte pas du tout si l'émigration
aujourd'hui à nier les composés de
femmes et d'hommes souvent invisibles
que vous ne voyez pas ou qui chef tôt le
matin j'ai pas si vous prenez le métro à
5h du mat moi je le prends
il ya quand même des gens qui ressemble
beaucoup à des immigrés j'ai pas si vous
regardez les travaux tient dans la ville
de paris en ce moment dans les tranchées
a beaucoup d'africains de quais avec les
marteaux piqueurs
je sais pas si vous regardez à la sortie
des écoles je les nounous qui viennent
attendre les petites ya beaucoup de
femmes sont aujourd'hui manger
maghrébine france active ayant fait leur
une femme et à qui on n'a pas peur qu'il
leur arrive quoi que ce soit il n'est
qu'on l'ait radicalise de la réalité
encore une fois c'est qu'on a un pays
aujourd'hui qui vit j'allais dire de
poncifs un peu facile de slogans de fans
qui nous donc on a des informations qui
sont fausses et concret de l'anc sur
jenny t on créer de l'anxiété ont montré
de l'homme de la peur on crée de la peur
dans nos pays ont créé de l'apr creusera
le sommet n os la réalité aujourd'hui
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
tous dit même ceux qui ont mis non ouais
absorbé immigration qu on était tous
favorables à la gestion des flux
migratoires vie d'amour on est tous à
brader des critères côté là mes voisins
il veut le faire croire connaît des
droits de l'hommistes combo ouvrez les
frontières au combat accueillir toute la
misère du monde de que ça limite c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai ces choses je
reprendrai le chiffre que j'ai pris au
début quand des chiffres non de 0,34
pour cent de la population immigrée voir
accueillir nombre de films gratuits
donc après cantons sur 5 200 mille
personnes à l'égard de tous notre
calibre
l'allemagne a accueilli 2 millions de
serrières des biens sont partis depuis
que la guerre ont sévèrement france